[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es eine
raffaello erdbeertorte warum fragt ihr
euch wahrscheinlich oder auch nicht ich
hab euch auf instagram gefragt was ich
mit all meiner raphael ausmachen soll
ich habe in letzter zeit so einiges am
besuch bekommen immer mal wieder wurde
über venlo mitgebracht weil ich mag
raffaello auch total gern und genießt
sogar total arbeitszeit ich so viele
übrig dass ich dachte okay die
verarbeite ich jetzt in einer torte
beziehungsweise nehme visiert
inspiration für eine erdbeertorte und
wir starten jetzt auch erstmal mit der
creme den boden habe ich nämlich
vorgebacken dazu sage ich euch nachher
noch was und für die creme habe ich
jetzt hier meine küchenmaschine denn ich
mache jetzt die creme die ich am
liebsten habe ich nehme mascarpone
frischkäse und sahne und schlag das
alles in einer schüssel das funktioniert
aber nur wenn alle zutaten kalt sind die
comments frisch aus dem kühlschrank sehr
gut und die risse ist auch kalt gerade
jetzt im sommer rückschlüsse schneebesen
aufsatz befuhr in den kühlschrank
stellen habt ihr gar keine probleme oder
mit kaltem wasser absolut trockenen hat
richtig gut
[Musik]
bestandteile war nicht sehr fest also
mascarpone und frischkäse und das ganze
lokal jetzt durch sahne auf und alles in
allem ist das eine creme die am ende zum
befüllen benutze zum äußeren bestreichen
und für die deko für die häubchen um
drauf deswegen liebe ich diese creme und
gerade im sommer wenn es schnell gehen
muss und man hier auch nicht so lange in
der küche stehen ist einfach perfekt
puderzucker und wann in exakt ich auch
schon mit dazu und seine fest dass ich
erst nach einer halben minute ungefähr
ein riesen
[Musik]
und zack ist die creme fertig wie
schnell das ging also ruckzuck und ich
habe jetzt hier erdbeeren da hab ich mir
die schönsten beiseite gelegt für die
deko später und den rest habe ich klein
geschnitten um ein bisschen boden das
ist ein grundrezept das kennt ihr schon
dass verlinkt ich euch in die infobox
und ich schreibe euch auch ganz genau
die mengenangaben die ich verwendet habe
denn wir brauchen für dieses rezept nur
zwei bilden
und deshalb werde ich meinen bis geboten
ist komplett abgekühlt jetzt einmal in
der hälfte durch teilen und dann können
wir schon anfang mit dem schichten
[Musik]
jetzt werde ich noch die creme ein
bisschen aufpimpen ich habe mir aber
vorab ein viertel erstmal zur seite
getan das brauche ich später noch für
die deko und den rest da werde ich jetzt
kokosraspeln dazugeben und einfach mit
dem teig scheibe einrühren
[Musik]
ihr nehmt euch jetzt ein tortenring zu
hilfe und bestreicht schon mal ein
bisschen die oberfläche des ersten
bodens das brauchen wir damit die
erdbeeren ist so ein bisschen dran
haften bleiben und dann kommt auf jeden
fall noch mehr creme dazu und ich mache
das jetzt auch so dass die erdmann bei
mir nur auf den ersten bodenkontakt mit
dem anstieg auch sehr schön vorstellen
wenn dann der boden ist erdbeeren und
dann oben nur noch weiße schichten
[Musik]
sollen die obere schicht gebe ich jetzt
noch ein paar versteckte halbierte
raphael los damit man sich dann an
schnitt auch richtig freut
[Musik]
jetzt ist ja oben auch alles glatt
verstrichen und da wir jetzt sehr feste
creme haben haben wir jetzt gerade noch
keine kühe zeit das heißt ich kann den
bug rahmen also den tortenring mein
backform löser direkt einmal entfernen
und dann die seiten auch noch mit creme
bestreichen
[Musik]
so ihr süßen nachdem ihr dann die torte
rundherum nochmal bestrichen haben
einmal komplett mit kokosraspeln
umhüllen und ich bin die sieht so schon
irgendwie ganz cool aus minimalistisch
einfach mit kokos bombe aber wir müssen
jetzt natürlich noch mit erdbeeren und
raffaello dekorieren weil das einfach
hübsch ist er sieht einfach hübsch aus
so ungemein folgendes ihr müsst euch
jetzt einen kleinen löffel nehmen denn
unsere sahnehäubchen also die creme die
wir uns hier am anfang bei seite gelegt
haben die habe ich in einen spritzbeutel
gefüllt mit stern telefone dran
die same hält nicht auf den kokosraspeln
deshalb macht er war folgendes ihr
schiebt so ein bisschen also da wo ihr
die tupfer platzieren möchte schiebt ihr
die kokosraspeln beiseite und dann leg
uhr ihr tier ganz einfach einfach der
fantasie freien lauf lassen
[Musik]
tadaa fertig ist die erdbeere dort ich
finde die so so hübsch und geschmacklich
ist sie natürlich auch mega wenn ich
durfte sich schon probieren aber auf
instagram machen wir immer noch
zusätzlich den tester ist passend zum
video also wenn ihr uns auf installieren
und ich volk dann holt das jetzt ganz
schnell nach schreibe ich euch auch hier
unten in die video beschreibung und was
ihr euch noch dazuschreiben sind
natürlich die ganz genaue mengenangaben
und dann könnt ihr ab zu kaufland und
dann einfach mal das ganze einkaufen und
nach machen und dann freue ich mich
natürlich über fotos postet sie auch
gerne auf instagram dann gucke ich mir
sie an und jetzt wünsche ich euch
einfach nur noch ganz viel freude beim
nachmachen dieser wunder wunderschön
torte und wir sehen uns dann beim
nächsten rezept video oder einem blog
oder auf meinem neuen format geht s
kitchen hacks falls man nicht kennt das
video werde ich euch auch am ende
nochmal verlinken also bis dann tschüss
eure ki
[Musik]